eh bien je salue tout le monde
sait ce que j -c et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour
l'épisode du top 5 de la
connerie alors aujourd'hui je
dois vous prévenir qu'on a des
gens qu'on voit de chance des
enfants
soirée debels meilleure forme
l'armée serbe
de macédoine gérante la
dynamique c'est tout cela
enfin bref allez c'est parti on
commence tout de suite
alors en cinquième position on
retrouve le caractère ambigu
c'est papa papa papa
la quête d'une place alors
votre capitaine donc est situé
dans le quartier
alors c'est quelqu'un avec qui
on a marre de la ville fois les
jeux aire et la chaîne des
jeunes juste pour faire chier
les autres joueurs est bloqué
dans un coin avec son ami alors
regardez celui-ci va péter un
câble de lancer de tels textes
réprimant les frères et c'est
une église sacré capitaine
belliot
en quatrième position on
retrouve donc bas étage j'ai
parlé ce point avec pierre
emprunt qui lance des balles la
gsma a dit avoir hâte que ça
passe les comètes doigt
d'honneur serait fatale
avec en prime des doigts
beaucoup de gens sont en tout
cas c'est un très joli bagage
à un devoir une ville de
baillargues chaplin
en troisième position on
retrouve donc le col black ops'
ps
qui va dans ce sens que
stratégique
l'enseignante montrant deux
hommes l'équipe a fait un super
elle assure qu' il appartient en
attendant de contester le droit
d'apprendre comment
encore enfin bon côté lança
son collègue va malheureusement
jamais touché
sa mère e pas tout simplement
faire le point ce cas car
là-bas à la même date hors
cac havas a fait du bien et il
n'a jamais touché le sol
elle était à toi comme la cote
alors en deuxième position on
retrouve d'eau dans les poumons
700 probablement le plus
quelqu'un qui aime dans la
balance le temps le parquet de
bruges trkr on arrive à faire
en fait je pense qu'il vient
d'acheter le cio qui s'était
cassé les deux bras et de
cerveaux avec
alors que l'opérateur la grande
hadary qui la reprend il a
renoncé à faire et des rares
et mer comme une merde
bravo à toi de d'autant plus
qu'elle couchait à la dernière
minute
valable
en première position on
retrouve la clinique st non il
n'a pas fait les choses à
moitié il lance un spectateur
bondy et icq
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler
paris ne sait si les partager
regardez banelings
ce sujet
l arme au t4 et bofa et bravo à
toi black phoenix
le top 5 de la connerie épisode
numéro de téléphone terminée
alors si vous voulez participer
c'est très simple il vous
suffit de m'envoyer
un message privé de tubes avec
le lien du pib donc évidemment
il faut que ce soit votre clip
pop
et si vous êtes gentils regard
des chargements
au nord on fait mais on se sert
à rien je prendrai les vidéos
de youtube
donc voila vous envoyer un
message pays des tubes comme
j'étais absente de la connerie
vous mettez le lien de la vidéo
vous mettez qui construisit trop
lol lol j'étais en super qui
étaient là là là
et puis voilà et puis s'était
déclaré dans une lettre à sa
femme dans ta salle de la
tannerie
en tout cas sagesse que cet
épisode monde vous aura plu je
vous dis à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
ça demande par thébaux bien